these banks are what I call zombie banks
that is they have negative net worth
the only way that uh Executives and
shareholders can come out out of it
really well is if they go out and take
big gambles and they pay off and if
those gambles don't pay off it'll be on
us the taxpayers to pay for it
so that has to be regulated they're
going to be put in a straight jacket so
we are going to have you know we don't
see it immediately but we're going to
have over the next few months the next
several years a much more regulated
banking system now could you explain a
little bit more what you mean by the
phrase zombie Banks
uh it's just a bank where if you marked
all of its assets and liabilities to
Market or if you just said all right
today you just have to sell all your
assets and pay off your depositors you
know liquidate the bank
uh if you tried to liquidate the bank
you would not end up uh with any any
anything left for the shareholders and
Executives so this and I call it as it's
called a zombie it's not really my term
it goes back to the Savings and Loan
crisis when the Savings and Loans
were given the opportunity to keep going
even though that they were they were
insolvent they went nuts they bought
junk bonds they bought commercial real
estate and as uh one Economist pointed
out what what what the zombie Banks
would
savings loans would do is they would pay
higher interest rates because they were
so desperate to kind of you know keep
gambling and they would buy weaker uh
invest in weaker loans and what does
that do to a healthy bank or Savings and
Loan well now they're you know their
ability to compete has gone away so
these zombies are really dangerous and
that's why uh there will be
justifiably very tight regulations as we
speak the FED is the most bankrupt Bank
in the country
you know they're they're not going to
collapse they can always take more money
from the treasury but that is just
that's just the reality they they are in
the position of svb in terms of you know
the market value of their portfolio
um so I think you know when you go so
you know I think the process by which
SVP went down is as I described it when
you talk about blame then you have to
talk about who could have done
differently
and you know a lot of people would say I
think this is really strange but a lot
of people would say that the uh
venture-backed
um firms should have behaved differently
they'll say well they shouldn't have put
you know five million dollars in deposit
at this one bank they should have spread
their deposits around they shouldn't
have put the money in
and I've also heard the op sort of the
opposite which is they shouldn't have
all taken their money out
a couple weeks ago they should have left
it in so they shouldn't have put as much
in when they thought the bank was
solvent and they shouldn't have taken as
much out when they thought the bank was
in trouble so that's you know okay it
it's probably true that if they hadn't
done those things we wouldn't have had
this bank run but that kind of blame I
don't fit the blame that I think
I'm inclined to is to go all the way
back to that deficit spending and the
quantitative easing
uh there you're really putting the whole
country at risk there's no you know it
did it does not end well it it leads to
the inflation the inflation leads to the
high interest rates the high interest
rates bankrupt a bunch of companies
including a huge portion of the banking
system I think there's something like
still 600 billion dollars of embedded
losses in the in all the banks and only
about 2 trillion in equity so they've
lost about a third of their equity
um so all that I trace back to the loose
deficit spending and the quantitative
easing all of this raises questions
about what we call moral hazard and
that's a question that
um uh Larry Summers the former treasury
secretary former president Harvard
um said is not something to worry about
uh at this or you know he said in the
lead up to the bailout of the depositors
that it's not really a question that uh
can be front of mind for Regulators I
don't think this is a time for moral
hazard lectures or for talk about
teaching people uh lessons we have
enough strains and challenges uh in the
economy without adding the collateral
consequences of uh a breakdown in an
important sector Larry is my age he
remembers the Savings and Loan crisis
and he knows what moral hazard is but he
also knows that you know this is this
this is an emergency that if you if you
let
the
uh if you stick with the 250 000 ceiling
obviously a lot of tech firms get wiped
out and you know I don't feel like they
deserved it and I don't think I think it
would have been horrible for all of the
the people who worked for them it'll
cause cause all sorts of Chaos
uh and on top of that you have all these
other Banks where you know everyone can
you know can look at their financial
statements and see that you know a
certain percentage of them are
underwater not as badly as svb but they
are under water and so you'll have Bank
runs all over the place Total Chaos in
the financial system so yeah to worry
you worry about moral hazard tomorrow
not today I don't think Larry would say
you never worry about moral hazard and I
think he knows you're creating a ton of
moral hazard and my point about zombie
Banks is that they are the ones who the
owners there are the ones who have lots
of moral hazard especially now that all
their deposits are guaranteed if they're
underwater they have nothing to lose by
taking money to Las Vegas and betting
and they have everything to gain and the
only thing that stops them from doing
that is regulation and that means that
the regulation is going to be tighter
and I think that that is going to last
forever there's this basic Trend that
government
Financial policy whether it's monetary
policy whether it's regulatory policy it
all the policies that survive are the
policies that allow government to
allocate credit to its preferred uses
especially to its own spending you know
as far as more Hazard goes I mean at
least the um shareholders were not built
out right so there was no you know
there's still risk from investing in a
poorly managed Bank
um
you know as far as the positives go most
indicators show that they would have
gotten like 80 cents back on their
dollar
um if that were allowed to to play out
um you know it's not I don't think it's
a moral case that those depositors had
to be bail out but I from their
perspective of preventing future Bank
runs in an emergency I can see why they
wanted to do it yeah but like you know
most moral hazard decisions are kind of
that Trend to fix the problem now uh and
then address the moral hazard later and
then never really address the moral
hazard
um either because they just don't or
because it's it's you know they've kind
of created a situation that we can't
really address it
um and so I I you know I think that's
just a general Trend that just keeps
happening there's a lot of talk about
abandoning any effort to fight inflation
I think and I think John Cochran would
think that any effort to fight inflation
has to include a serious effort at
reigning in the deficit and not just
anyone here but all the out years and
that includes includes Social Security
and Medicare
are we going to see that probably not so
does that mean we're going to relive the
1970s with a lot of floundering and you
know random policy changes that don't do
anything and you get a lot more
inflation so I anyway it's it's not an
easy thing to answer I just say that the
one precedent that comes to my mind says
watch out for you know lots more
inflation and and more troubles and just
to be very clear about that why is it
that bringing the deficit and eventually
the debt under control is the essential
component there from your Viewpoint
because ultimately that's what
you know how the government injects
money or wealth into the economy is by
just running these deficits and if you
don't and and
you know how do you how do you get rid
of government debt you can deformally
default you say wake up tomorrow and say
sorry bondholders you're not getting
anything
or you can actually cut spending raise
taxes or you can inflate it away
there's no sentiment to
formally default there's no sentiment to
bring the deficit under control so what
you're left with it seems to me is
inflation
hey thanks for watching that excerpt
from my conversation with Lynn Alden and
Arnold cling about the Silicon Valley
Bank meltdown and what caused it who's
to blame what to expect next for the U.S
banking sector you can watch the full
conversation by clicking here or on the
link in the description below and
subscribe to reason TV and watch these
conversations live every Thursday at 1
pm Eastern